forse non la si incontra una ricetta a
bollone vole l'hanno arrestato questo è
certo
vorrei essere il tuo culo a fine
giornata ecco perché gli inglesi
dovrebbero rimanere in inghilterra anche
se mi sa che è l'australiano ciao
ragazzi bentornati a una puntata di
cucina buttata scusate se oggi non sono
entusiasta come al solito perché stiamo
per andare a fare un qualcosa di
abominevole per quanto mi riguarda
arresto delle funzioni vitali e allo
stesso tempo della persona da parte
della polizia e delle forze armate
io sento giorno di elicottero che si
avvicina quindi sbrighiamoci a detta del
grande chef che ci propone questo piatto
sto parlando di tono che han tipico nome
italiano che ci insegna come fare una
pasta italiana un video che ha fatto 9
milioni e passa di visualizzazioni che
vuol dire che nel mondo non milioni e
passa di persone pensano che fare la
pasta tutta quanta all'interno di una
sola pentola sia una cosa intelligente
non una roba punibile dalla legge
noi a cucina buttata non ci facciamo
parlare spalle ho preso la mia pentola e
direi a questo punto di partire con gli
ingredienti e poi con il procedimento
per fare sta pentolata de ficchy avrete
bisogno di spaghetti ai quali non volete
per niente bene
olio extravergine per motori pecorino ma
va bene anche neve artificiale per
presepi con motorini aglio basilisco una
ci fu da per avere un secondo motivo per
piangere è infine sale e peperoncino e
pepe nero come il mio umore
posizione intanto questa paura pentola
che non ho mai usato nella vita in
generale sul fuoco e mi metto già a
lavorare agli ingredienti in evidente
che stava cercando di scappare in tutti
i modi un errore un orrore si ma posso
dirti una cosa la faccio a mente aperta
perché è giusto che roba di questo tipo
che non aveva nemmeno provato possa in
qualche modo eventualmente risultare
cuore a me ricorda un po la pasta quella
di vista che ha mai fatto della ricordi
a castagnaro mamma mia
siccome era una merda sarà sempre più
star orribile con la cosa giusta il gran
merdone con direbbe qualcuno ne abbiamo
fatta de faccia solo se siete venti
molto forti prendete un coltello
altrimenti fate tagliare a qualcun altro
di più forte che non sa in che modo
utilizzerete questi ingredienti
prendiamo i nostri spaghetti distendiamo
all'interno del sarcofago giusti giusti
all'interno della bara parto la cipolla
ok mette molta più cipolla di pomodorini
questo come la pasta alla cipolla fa eco
una cosa che dice tagliare tutto maniera
molto sottile effettivamente ha senso
perché dal momento che verrà tutto
bollito insieme alla pasta per una
decina di minuti manco è possibile
decidere moticea come può cuocersi in
dieci minuti mi metterò la con molto
calda attese il tipico personaggio che
poi l'assaggio e gli piace può essere
perché se una persona aperta alimenti
voglio dire ho assaggiato laner che
potete usare la sua tecnica della
cipolla che ci penso io una nuova
tecnica della bolla basta ti prego
pazzesca fu anche l'altra volte posso
farti da vedere siamo finiti a piangere
settimana posso fartela vedere o no di
melo bari ci tengo innanzitutto a
riversare tutte quante le persone che mi
hanno mandato sotto 23 non ironie
nickname
su instagram questo metodo ma te lo
faccio vedere subito avete bisogno di
una felpa con cappuccio
gente che avrete bisogno di un coperchio
un astronauta no va bene non ci credo ma
se il buon capo non solo anche simone
epoca questo metodo è vincenti simo però
veramente sicuro non al gambero rosso a
questo punto venivano cipolla e la
sistemiamo nella pentola tipo motori e
in italy dati sottilissimi fa ridere che
verrà sto spiegando come se doveste
farla a casa
non mi sembra così proprio lo sciopero
beh perché lui era il taglio dello chef
lui è velocissimo pratica un coltello
migliore infatti gianni ora che andiamo
nel loro ufficio e nella nuova cucina e
qui lo dico e qui lo nego
perché sarà una cosa la qualità stiamo
ancora lavorando tra parentesi secondo
voi come sarebbe fico il design della
nuova cucina cioè come immaginate che
dovrebbe essere qualsiasi cosa una cosa
che mi piace non deve per forza essere
bidono mie cose così le quali uno pensa
subito se pensa a buttata in sono
curioso di leggerlo non ce l'ha è la tua
idea si potrà avere un coltello migliore
anche una mano è certo ma di sicuro non
un palato migliore ci siamo quasi
ragazzi stiamo per fare
sto pentolame de merda ma farlo in a
a dimettersi si vuole essere pure capito
artistico scusami gianni soccorso te lo
rifaccio guarda riali sollevo e deliri
butto dentro per farti vivere questo
momento pazzesco basilico poi prende
maglio vieni qui vieni 4 e rai non
scappare ma il picchio dal fare carino è
sì olio carino anche questo guarda sale
pepe anche qui mai peroncino vado molto
più accorto dei minus di bhutto così
stanno per attentamento carmina faccia
che movimenta prima cosa che verrà da
fare una volta che ci sono fatte le
ditte fischiato l'anno di un'ora come
lei gioca poi c'è soffrendo lacrime
lagerback nel culo lui ragazzine mette
così anche meno a occhio il fornaio non
si può accendere scusami demarcazione
posso dire che stai facendo una
riproduzione molto vedeva la tutele però
prende queste anche se pure quelle più
lunghe
può essere che abito così ho più
possibilità di stare lontano dalla
bonino invece così se più vicino garanti
ok la lunghissima comincia a muovere ma
adesso che mori che sono luca in
incazzano sicuramente posso dirti solo
una cosa cucinare tutti quanti gli
spaghetti in realtà se riesce a prendere
bene il tempo all'interno della pentola
sin dall'inizio prime note dolenti tirar
fuori tutto quanto il loro glutine
quindi teoricamente quale dovesse finire
bene quindi al dente e tutto quanto
proprio virtuosissima a livello
concettuale perché non l'ascoli mai in
questo sono curioso il resto non so che
dirvi questa è una risposta tura
completa e la facciamo a stagione
ringraziano e diciamo loro che l'ha
fatta e non rompete i [ __ ] ragazze
si vendono di queste cose di merda
piacciono le macchine miseria di su
instagram un po di persone che mi hanno
detto dopo anni mi sono iscritto
iscritta iscritta asterisco al tuo
canale perdonami non ragazzi io sono
umile se anche dopo anni voi vi
iscrivete siete sempre in tempo per
recuperare tutto quello che non avete
fatto fino ad oggi ogni iscrizione un
giorno di povertà almeno per il
sottoscritto ogni iscrizione vuol dire
ci tengo a te per voi un click col mouse
su una roba freddano per me è una dolce
carezza sul viso
premete quel bottone e metteteci il
cuore se vi siete iscritti
guardando questo video scrivetemi qua
sotto ci ho messo il cuore
cambiate con la calza campanella
quasimodo per le campane hanno tre
normale con di tissi ma mi raccomando
una suocera è sarebbe un disastro
la palla nel piano lo sai quale capitolo
di quella libro si chiama la palla del
piano chissà se qualcuno ci è arrivato
la falla nel piano harry potter
bravissimo quale ricordo quale il 7 lo
sai ora non lo sapevo perché il 7 ho
letto solo in inglese
secondo me questa vasta non saprebbe
niente lo dico subito un giornale ma io
questa cosa ci avrei buttato in due
secondi concentrato di pomodoro è
oggettivamente cremosi ma è anche
leggera in realtà perché non ho
soffritto un cazzo
no gianmarco biglie la saggia prendiamo
i piatti dei miei amici 23 bassi sono
stupendi capisci perché padova questo la
piazza famosa se non sbaglio la mia idea
dietro questo piatto sul motivo perché
si chiama padova è perché c'è il giotto
a padova con questo cielo per a questa
nuova sono mezzano
amen sarà questo il motivo grazie
gianmarco laureato in architettura cos'è
milano perché secondo me il pavimento
quello di dove ci stanno le palle del
toro quella lì dove tu devi girare col
pallone sulla palla del toro firenze di
e palermo c'è quindi te hai appena
infamato mezza italia mettendoci questa
pasta dentro pecorino basilisco e la
pasta le seconde cesure scotta da come
scopo molti direbbero che perfetta
presente che mi piace è ancora durello
cremosi ma insapore sento un piccante
ragazze è pronto ma finiscono non senti
falle via padova un altro è molto
pesante alla fine morirà uccidere non è
molliccio anche incanterà di nas tiera
lavi bastato sentirsi male però c'è
gente c'è un ragazzo è squisita io dico
da gianni gran successo questa l'abbiamo
cucinate con le dita dei piedi ha fatto
tutta quanta in una sola notte
inquadratura cordeglio dove quanto so
bell stì piatti i ragazzi la visione che
cita i suoi piatto mio palermo 2 milano
como del palermo guglielmo a palermo
allora lei a milano ci vedo mi vedo
molto confusi sulla scelta delle città e
quindi non c'è scritto con insomma come
posso dire che era buona ma sopravvivo
d'accesso di mangiarla angioy o meno
buoni lo sapevamo che cerca peroncino e
abbiamo figlia di un sempre a niente
bene e male con te la meriti la loro
soffice chiarezza su molto non lo
carrettate anzi carezzate lo scrive
questa carica e per la b vogliamo
ricordarla così wasp italiano è bianca
un terribile
ho scelto io ragazzi grazie perché sarà
all'altezza vedo come la vigna un po
sopra le righe ma sta bevendo senza
panna doccia come i ciclisti detto ciao
ragazzi piatto assolutamente promosso
solo feriti da ca tesi su instagram ma
soprattutto se avete qualcuno dal quale
non percepì peroncino fatevi lo assaggia
subito dopo e soddisfazione oggi noi ci
vediamo giovedì con un nuovo video alle
[Musica]